And the way to mae the circles properly displayed is by this block of code here.
Currently all the circles are overlapping in the top left of the screen and
visually don't have any representation, because we haven't set a radius or
a fill for them.
So what's happening in this code here, is we're saying find me all
the circles on the webpage which there's 836 of them there.
Change the .cxf attribute of the circle, which stands for center x, so change
the x position of the circle, according to the anonymous accessor function.
And again, since this function gets past to d, a different bound data object,
every time it's called, we can position every circle at a completely different
place on our chart corresponding to what's actually contained in its bound data.
In this case, the pattern to do this in d3 is to take your scale object and
pass in the column that corresponds to, in this case, the x axis.
So, since our x axis corresponds to the date of the game we pass the date,
which in this case is a JavaScript date object, to our time scale
which converts it from a date object to a pixel value and return that from our
anonymous excessor function to set the exposition of that circle.
Again, that was quite a lot, so
let's explore this in the web console by inserting a debugger statement.
Refreshing the page and jumping to the debugger inside of
our anonymous accessor function, we can now inspect what d is.
In this case, we've broken on the first game.
So game one, which has attendance 25,000.
Looking at d[date],
was have a JavaScript data object corresponding to May 27th of the year 1934.
But again, d3 needs a pixel value to know where to actually draw the circle.
We can't say draw the circle at position May 27th.
And the way to go from a date, in this case, to a pixel value for
our given chart is to use the time scale we created earlier.
So in this case May 27 1934 happens to correspond to
x pixel position 132.6 and so forth.
And looking at the rest of the code here, we set the x position of the center of
the circle to correspond to the attendance column.
So again, whatever attribute we're trying to set in this case cy, gets set to be
whatever gets returned from the accessor function for an individual data point.